We're in problem number seven.
Let me switch colors.
The average of the weights
of 14 books is p pounds.
In terms of p, what is
the total weight of
the books in pounds?
So this comes up all the
time in the SAT.
The average of weights of
14 books is p pounds.
So if you had weight 1, plus
weight 2, plus-- if I were to
add all 14 books, that's just
the weights of all the 14
books, and I were to divide
by 14, that is equal to p.
This is just the definition
of average.
You add up the weights of all
the books, divide by the
number of books, and you
get the average.
Well, if you multiply both sides
by 14 you get w1-- you
get the sum of all of the
weights of the books is equal
to what? p times 14.
And what are they asking?
In terms of p, what is
the total weight
of all of the books?
Well, this is the total weight
of all of the books, right?
I just take the weight of the
first one, plus the weight of
the second one, and keep adding
until I get to the
weight of the 14th, and that
is equal to p times 14.
And that is choice E.
14p.
Choice E.
Next problem.
Problem eight.
Draw the axes.
This is x and y.
And then they draw-- let me do
it in a different color.
They have point A, which
is 2, negative 1.
So it's 2 comma negative 1.
So this is the point
x is equal to 2.
If we were to go down, this
is y equal negative 1.
And then they have point
B, which is k,t.
And then they have point C
up here-- C is 2 comma 5.
So it's 2 comma and this is 5.
Point B is the midpoint of AC.
So point B is this
midpoint of AC.
So this distance is the
same as that distance.
What is the value of t?
So what's its y value?
We know what k is, k's going
to have to be 2.
So what's the y value?
So the y value's essentially
just going to be the average
of this y value and that y
value, because it's right in
the middle of the two.
So it's going to be 5
plus minus 1 over 2,
which is equal to what?
That's equal to 4 over 2,
which is equal to 2.
So this point, right here,
is going to be 2 comma 2.
And all I did is I took the
average of the y values.
The other way you could have
thought about it is, what is
this total distance?
What's the distance from
5 to negative 1?
Well, that's 6.
So this distance would be 3.
And what's 5 minus 3?
It's 2 as well.
But the easiest way is just to
average this y value and this
y value, and you'll get the
y value for the midpoint.
And that is choice C.
Next problem.
Problem nine.
So far I didn't have to draw
anything, this is pretty good.
If k times 2x plus 3, times x
minus 1 is equal to 0, and
they also tell us that x is
greater than 1, what is the
value of k?
So let's see, if for this times
this, times this to
equal 0, at least one of them
has to be equal to 0.
Maybe more than one,
maybe all of them.
In order for this term to be 0,
what does x have to equal?
Well, for x to be 0 here-- for
this term to be 0, sorry-- x
would have to be equal to 1.
How did I get that?
I said x minus 1
is equal to 0.
Add 1 to both sides,
x is equal to 1.
Well, they told us that x
is greater than 1, so x
cannot equal 1.
So this cannot happen.
That cannot happen, because
x is greater than 1.
So we know that this is not 0.
This term is not-- this might
not equal-- that's
not equal to 0.
What has to be a value for
x for this term to be 0?
2x plus 3 equals 0.
Subtract 3 from both sides.
2x is equal to minus 3.
x is equal to minus 3/2.
Once again, they tell us that
x has to be greater than 1.
If x is greater than 1, we know
that x cannot be minus
3/2, because obviously
this is less than 1.
So once again, we know that this
term does not equal 0.
So if this term doesn't equal 0,
this term doesn't equal 0.
But when I multiply all three
of these terms I get 0.
This k has to equal 0.
This is non-zero, this
is non-zero.
If I'm getting 0 when I multiply
them, k has to be 0,
and that's choice B.
Next problem.
Problem number 10.
Let's see if I have enough
space to do it.
I should just clear
it every time.
If all men in the Williams
family are over 6 feet tall--
that's not true of my family, of
the Khan family; maybe one
day if we eat right-- which
of the following
statements must be true?
If all of the men in the
Williams' family are over 6
feet tall, which of
the following
statements must be true?
Choice A, no man under 6 foot
tall is a member of the
Williams family.
Sure.
That sounds good to me.
Choice A, no man under 6 feet
tall is a member of the
Williams family.
For example, I am 5 foot 9.
If I was a member of the
Williams family, then the
first statement could not be
have been said, that all men
in the Williams family
are over 6 feet tall.
So that makes sense, all men
in the Williams family are
over 6 feet tall.
So that means that no man under
6 foot tall is a member
of the Williams family, because
if there were then you
couldn't have said that all men
in the Williams family are
over 6 feet tall.
That probably required the most
talking and the least
writing on my behalf,
but hopefully that's
a convincing answer.
Problem 11.
Let me know if it wasn't.
What is the radius of a circle
that has circumference of pi.
So we know that circumference
is equal 2 pi r.
And they're telling us that
the circumference is pi.
So pi is equal to 2 pi r.
Divide both sides by 2
pi, you get pi over 2
pi is equal to radius.
Divide the numerator and
the denominator by
pi, you get 1, 1.
So you get 1/2 is equal to the
radius, and that is choice B.
Pretty straightforward, eh?
Problem 12.
If y is directly proportional
to x squared and y equals--
OK, so when I say directly
proportional, that means y is
equal to some constant, we don't
know what it is, y is
equal to some constant
times x squared.
That's what directly
proportional means.
It means it's some constant
times x squared.
y is directly proportional to
x squared, and y is equal to
1/8 when x is equal to 1/2.
So y is equal to 1/8 is equal
to k times when x is 1/2.
So when x is 1/2, that's
all we're saying.
So what does this tell us?
That means that 1/8 is
equal to k times 1/4.
Multiply both sides by 4, times
4, you get 4/8 is equal
to k, because this
cancels out.
And 4/8 is the same
thing as 1/2.
So the relationship is, y is
equal to 1/2 x squared, and
now what are they asking us?
What is the positive value of
x when y is equal to 9/2?
So they're saying when y equals
9/2, let's solve for x
in the positive value.
9/2 is equal to 1/2 x squared.
Multiply both sides by 2,
this 2 cancels here,
this 2 cancels here.
I was multiplying.
So you get 9 is equal
to x squared.
So they want the positive
value of x.
So x is equal to plus
or minus 3.
And they want the positive
value, so x is equal to
positive 3.
And that's choice D.
Choice D.
Let me do the next problem
in the next video.
I'll see you soon.